bonjour j'ai rodriguez bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin sur
rtl france pour parler de cet
anniversaire trois ans de mouvement 17
novembre 2018 c'était la première
manifestation d'ampleur des gilet jaune
on est également par skype avec del
poulin président du syndicat gilet jaune
elle est constructive première question
bonjour bonjour david poulin première
question pour vous jérôme rodriguez 3
ans déjà dans quel état d'esprit vous
êtes ce matin
c'est compliqué parce que ça fait quand
même une dizaine de jours où j'ai à
faire ou aux médias justement pour
parler des trois ans parce que les
choses se préparent en amont et ça m'a
permis justement de réfléchir et de
faire d'eux des remises en caution sur
le mouvement il ya pas mal de choses à
dire mais à l'échelle du pourquoi on est
descendus dans la rue force est de
constater que la situation est bien pire
que celle pourquoi on dit descendus dans
la rue ne serait-ce que si on se fixe
sur ce fameux prix de l'essence il est
beaucoup plus chère voire de 20 % de ce
qu'il n'était il ya trois ans auparavant
donc la situation est critique le covin
nous l'a mis encore encore plus critique
on n'a aucune solution à apporter je
regardais justement les infos tout à
l'heure en patientant ne serait ce que
sur le aucune question autour de
l'hôpital autour de ddd
des choses qu'on pourrait donner à
l'hôpital pour pouvoir soigner
aujourd'hui les français on l'a vu par
le cos vide on continue à voir
aujourd'hui enfin il ya beaucoup de
questions gilet jaune aujourd'hui qui se
pose qu'est-ce qu'on fait de notre
argent de santé en 240 milliards d'un
côté 19 milliards de l'autre donc là
dessus si la situation est bien critique
pire qu'avant et c'est très compliqué à
analyser le pourquoi du comment les gens
aujourd'hui ne réagissent pas est ce
qu'il faut
l'énergie du désespoir pour que les gens
soient concernés aient commencé à
réaliser qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
va pas aujourd'hui dans ce pays est
quelque peu dans le monde je sais pas
mais en tout cas on continue d'essayer
de revendiquer d'apporter des solutions
il ya beaucoup de gilet jaune qui ont
pensé à des solutions il serait peut
être important est temps aujourd'hui de
leur donner un tant soit peu
d'importance parce que toute proposition
est bonne à mettre sur la table et à
discuter david pilard vous êtes dans le
même état d'esprit que jérôme rodriguez
ce matin trois ans après le début du
mouvement des gilets jaunes bas la
situation ne s'est pas arrangé on voit
bien de toute manière tout à l'heure
j'ai redit à juste titre il ne
comprenait pas eu ne comprenons pas
pourquoi les gens réagissent pas mais il
ya un élément de réponse est que l'état
aujourd'hui je vous la planche à billets
on est en train d'acheter les gens en
donnant de l'argent que nous n'avons pas
en aggravant une situation économique
pour nos enfants on est en train de
proposer à la nouvelle jeunesse d'avoir
une retraite plus tard avec divisé par
deux donc plus d'espoir donc le crois
que nous sommes dans un état très
dangereux dans le sens où la psychologie
collective est explosive je pense que la
moindre étincelle va se voir lors des
présidentielles parce que les gens
s'aperçoivent que manifester tous les
jours ça n'apporte que de la répression
la diabolisation à titre collectif y à
titre personnel parce que les exilés
jaune la plupart les leaders ont eu des
problèmes aussi personnelle et donc ils
se disent pas toute façon va aller se
défouler en mai dans les rôles dans les
urnes est de plus en plus on va
déstabiliser notre démocratie et cette
situation n'est pas tenable à moyen long
terme et le danger final c'est qu'on se
retrouve avec les extrêmes au pouvoir
est dans une impasse à la fois politique
et économique
et là ça deviendra beaucoup plus
dangereux que les gilet jaune jérôme
rodriguez 3 ans de combat trois ans de
violence en s'en souvient tous les
samedis avec ces répressions elles ces
personnes qui ont été qui ont perdu un
oeil comme vous d'ailleurs où des
membres comment ça se passe après trois
ans de lutte est ce que finalement la
répression a pris le dessus sur le
mouvement c'est un des éléments de
réponse de la politique française et ce
depuis 40 ans quand l'état français
français ou un président quelconque et
dans la capacité de répondre aux
attentes aujourd'hui de ce qu'il faut le
pays on ne répond que par la table dans
la tronche et ça c'est comment ça les
gens manifester à mai donc pour beaucoup
oui je vous garantis que quand certains
me regardent ils ont peur d'arriver en
manif ils ont peur de ce qu'ils vont
leur arrivée imaginez un chauffeur de
taxi qui aujourd'hui voudraient
manifester j'en discutais ce matin il
pourrait mettre la tête hors du pare
brise et perdra le hyper à noël il perd
son travail et c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que c'est plus
de 2400 blessés plus de trente éborgné
cinq mains arrachées plus de 1000
arrestations amnesty international a mis
en avant l'ensemble des gardes à vue qui
ont été prononcées et d aider peine
encourue est prononcée par les gilet
jaune au bout de 24 heures toute la
réalité de la répression du mouvement
aujourd'hui ça n'a été que ça et je vous
parle même pas de la diabolisation de la
diffamation des insultes subi et comme
le rappelait monsieur poulin à titre
personnel il faut voir ce que j'ai
ramassé aujourd'hui il ne fait pas bon
d'être un opposant politique je tiens
juste à préciser parce que je vais
rebondir ça s'est même pas de
l'opposition politique c'est tout
simplement des gens qui valait
aujourd'hui je pense au citoyen en
colère gilet jaune ou autres groupes de
citoyens en colère les seuls vrais
opposition au gouvernement en place
quand on voit aujourd'hui un un ministre
de l'intérieur qui dit qu'il ne peut pas
arrêter les fameux dalton à la sortie
d'un studio parce qu'ils n'ont rien fait
moi aujourd'hui je ne fais arrêter dans
la rue parce que je suis ce que je suis
et parce que je suis dans la rue et ça
aujourd'hui vous n'avez aucun
journaliste qui semble inquiète dans les
médias mainstream j'en parle bien sûr le
jus précise bien sûr de s'inquiéter
qu'aujourd'hui dans un pays libre comme
la france on m'arrête dans la rue parce
que je m'appelle jérôme rodriguez et
s'est pas retenu encore aujourd'hui à
messam est encore arrivé il ya deux
samedis en arrière le 14 juillet en
l'espace de 30 minutes je me suis arrêté
je vais au poste de police je ressors je
me refais arrêté mais on ne sait pas
pourquoi marc est telle que même les
policiers qui m'arrêtent ne savent pas
pourquoi ils m'arrêtent c'est juste un
ordre de la part du central de la
préfecture bon ça c'est un cas personnel
mais combien de gilet jaune l'ont vécue
combien de j les jaunes ont mis de côté
leur famille pour pouvoir être plus
présents samedi pouvoir revendiquer
militer donc ça aussi ça a été très
compliqué ça fait toujours plaisir
d'amener le petit au foot ou la petite
au volleyball ou autres tous sports
confondus enfin il ya plein de choses
qui rentrent en ligne de compte
manifestement parlant moins de monde
dans la rue moi je vais juste vous
donner un chiffre le 12 juillet macron
raccroche le micron le pendant le nom ni
le micro je gagne dix mille abonnés de
plus sur ma page en une nuit j'en ai
gagné 90 milles de plus si on l'était se
sont pas défilés jaune ce sont la
catégorie de personnes que par le
monsieur poulin c'est à dire des gens
qui aujourd'hui vont rentrer sur le
marché de la précarité le marché de la
misère qui n'ont pas l'habitude et euh
c'est pas des étincelles comme les jets
les jeunes ont pu mettre en place mais
ça va être des flammes parce que n'ont
pas l'habitude aujourd'hui de ce que les
jeunes connaissent depuis des années
c'est à dire le système d la débrouille
la démerde et surtout débrouille toi
tout seul on se souvient à l'époque de
trouver de la difficulté de trouver un
leader alors jérôme rudin et reste vous
faites partir de ces figures des vis des
jaunes david boulain finalement la force
de ce mouvement c'était de rassembler
des français de tous les horizons mais
ce que finalement ça n'a pas été aussi
sa faiblesse
disons qu'on a comparé les gilet jaune
comme un mouvement politique ou comme un
mouvement associatif en réalité c'était
un mouvement de la base c'est comme dans
un couple imaginez que ça fait 30 ans
que les gens sont ensemble et puis d'un
seul coup le couple dit jamais rien il
ya des non-dits à des petites crises et
puis un jour ça explose et on reproche
tout à l'autre bah c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé c'est la première étape
d'une explosion sociale parce que la
france est en colère les français sont
en colère depuis 40 ans parce que tout à
l'heure j'ai un gros dégueulasse disais
tout à l'heure que les régions ont connu
une répression diabolique de parement
une répression diabolisantes excessive
je vous donne un exemple est il normal
que le ministre de la justice soit
actuellement mise en examen et n'ai
aucune conséquence est il normal que
nicolas sarkozy qui a été condamné
aujourd'hui n'aille pas en prison alors
qu'un simple gilet jaune que l'on lui va
avoir le tort de manifester parce qu'il
en a marre de lutter il en a marre de la
justice dans ce pays là et parce qu'il
n'a plus d'espoir mais plus de koné plus
de répression que ces gens là on voit
bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va
plus dans notre pays la france est
totalement colère et les français
attendaient justement en crimée un
mouvement qui les suivent or le mot en
gilet jaune c'est pas un mot qui va
sauver les français c'est un thermomètre
qui est en train de dire ça ne va plus
du tout et qu'il faut justement remettre
tout à plat y compris nos institutions
ou compris notre modèle économique et
social pour pouvoir nous adapter au
monde d'aujourd'hui ils permettent de
recréer de l'espoir dans notre pays et
c'est pour ça qu'ils jugeront avec des
forces de proposition
il faut pas oublier que beaucoup de
français qui ont critiqué les gilet
jaune enfin ceux qui ont critiqué les
jeunes ont bénéficié aussi des réformes
et des démesures gilet jaune moi j'ai
croisé quelques à une fois c'est ce que
j'allais dire effectivement un vrai
français pas vous dire merci parce que à
emmanuel macron a quand même réagi en
débloquant de l'argent on le voit
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il a très peur
d'une une contestation sociale
concernant tchèque c'est pas de l'argent
que l'on veut c'est de l'espoir on le
voit aujourd'hui on est en train de
sortir le carnet de chèques que l'on n'a
pas on crée du désespoir encore plus
fort de demain on vous disais tout à
l'heure j'ai croisé des gens qui ont
critiqué les gilet jaune jordi barre
vous êtes contre le mouvement des jeux
wii c'est pas bien c'est des casseurs et
c'est ok et par contre vous avez
bénéficié de la prime macro oui j'ai
pris 2500 euros pense qu'il faut être
cohérent il faut renoncer à ces primes
là et l'a faite par des gens non donc on
voit bien que ce système de
diabolisation de répression à me donner
un exemple quand je manifestaient
pacifiquement en voyant milieu
manifestation des gens qu'elle voulait
s'infiltrer j'allais par les policiers
pour leur dire attendez il ya des gens
cagoulés qui sont en train de
s'infiltrer mais qui sont en train de
mettre le bordel on vous a répondu on a
des instructions on ne bouge pas donc on
voit bien qu'il ya des instructions d'en
haut pour diaboliser un mouvement de
comme l'a dit si justement jérôme il
n'ya pas le gouvernement en place et les
politiques aujourd'hui n'ont aucune
solution aux préoccupations des français
et ils vont essayer d'aller jusqu'au
bout d'une logique qui ne fonctionne
plus jusqu'à ce que ça pète et puis on
verra bien ce qui se passera derrière en
espérant que ça peut être pas trop fort
c'est un peu saxons jérôme rodriguez
très court vous disiez nous ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui c'est vivre
dignement de travail finalement c'est ça
on réclame pas l'aumône beaucoup de
s'interroge de nous traîner de finhan ou
d'assister
tiens à rappeler que je te rappeler une
chose dans ce pays la france 1 quand on
aide les pauvres ce qu on appelle ça de
l'assistanat quand on aide les riches on
appelle ça des subventions peut-être se
poser les bonnes questions aussi des
mouvements examen le mouvement n'est pas
mort
moi j'ai juste peut-être un rôle
aujourd'hui avertir que ça peut très mal
se passer derrière parce que les gens
arrivent un trop-plein que les braises
sont encore là qu'elles font ardente et
qu'il est grand temps de s'asseoir
autour d'une table de peut-être écouté
les français parce que les français sa
vente du foie gras dans le monde entier
alors qu'un président n'est pas capable
demande lui des sous-marins et vient
donner des leçons à ces français là
voilà merci jérôme rodriguez merci david
poulin d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france est ridicule pour revenir
sur les trois ans du mouvement des idées
jours